وقل للمتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيوم ان اليه مراقبه وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان كشفت عن انتهاكات
محتمله للاتفاق واضاف ان الانتهاكات شملت
استخدام المدفعيه والطائرات العسكريه
والمسيرات وان اليه مراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار اتصلت بطرفي النزاع
اليه مراقبه وقف اطلاق النار التي وضعناها
الى جانب الاتفاقيه التي تم توقيعها خلال
عطله نهايه الاسبوع كشفت وقوع انتهاكات
محتمله للاتفاقيه في الرابع والعشرين من
مايو وشملت هذه الانتهاكات استخدام
المدفعيه والطائرات العسكريه والمسيرات
هذا بالاضافه الى التقارير الموثوقه عن
ضربات جويه وقتال متواصل في قلب المنطقه
الصناعيه في الخرطوم نراقب الوضع بما في
ذلك الامتثال للشروط وقف اطلاق النار